[Music]
as fans of chicago fire now know jesse
spencer has left the building firehouse
51 that is in the fourth episode of the
show's 10th season his character matthew
casey goes to oregon to find out that
andy darden's sons aren't doing too well
after that he has a heart-to-heart
conversation with christopher herman in
which he basically says he is going to
leave chicago to help take care of them
in a subsequent episode casey deals with
the fallout from that decision including
his burgeoning romance with brett before
saying a final goodbye to the crew
spencer is one of the original chicago
firecast members having logged 200
episodes of the show since it started
airing in 2012. while his character is
supposedly going away for three years
there are no guarantees that the actor
will be back at all after such a long
time on the series though fans may be
wondering why the actor has decided to
leave now with the cat out of the bag
and his exit secured spencer has
explained his reasoning to the media in
a recent video interview with us weekly
spencer said that he actually wanted to
leave the show between its 9th and 10th
seasons but creator derek has talked him
into staying a few more episodes so he'd
have 200 of them on his resume as it
turned out his reasons for leaving the
show were entirely personal notably
spencer has been in network television
for 18 years straight which is obviously
a long time whichever way you cut it
spencer said there's other things that i
would like to do in the future and
there's some family that i need to take
care of
he added that he felt like his departure
storyline worked for him saying casey's
leaving and going to oregon therefore
for the right reasons you know it all
felt really organic but will spencer
return to the show at some point it's
possible in fact it sounds like talks
have already begun to bring him back to
tie up some loose ends during the same
interview haz was asked to spencer might
come back for a special occasion and he
gave an answer that should have fans
cautiously optimistic saying i'm hoping
i never try to predict what's going to
happen production-wise but we're in the
camp of whenever jesse wants to come do
an episode with us we will move
mountains on earth to make that happen
spencer clarified that he plans to stay
in chicago with his wife even though
he's stepping away from the show which
is a little ironic because the city's
harsh climate had him questioning
whether to remain on the series during
its early years obviously 200 episodes
on one tv show is a monumental
achievement for any actor and something
few in the profession will ever actually
experience it's also something that
spencer himself thought might not happen
in the early days of chicago fire cast
members leave shows or get let go for
any number of reasons ranging from
issues in their personal life to
decisions made by the writers for
spencer though it was the notoriously
frigid chicago winters that had him
unsure about his future on the series
during an interview with stage right
secrets about the 200th episode of
chicago fire spencer hailed the show's
crew as integral to the series longevity
while discussing the hard work the crew
regularly performed on the series he
made special mention of chicago's cold
temperatures spencer said i mean the
weather i didn't think i'd last a year
on the show after those winters i was
like i don't know if i can do this even
though he plans to stay in chicago now
that he has turned in his badge spencer
did indicate that he might start booking
vacations for himself during the winter
during his us weekly interview he said i
still am in chicago right now i'm not
running off to los angeles although i
might escape for a little bit of the
winter i might snowbird that's what i
hear people do wherever he goes here's
hoping he doesn't stray too far from the
windy city or the set of chicago fire
i'm gonna miss it i'm stepping away but
i'll be back
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]